well this is the first full day of
protests here at the g7 summit in
cornwall it all began
on the other side of the coast not here
in synagogues but over in falmouth
where there was a youth climate strike
it was the u.s president and uk prime
minister in blimp form that started
protests in falmouth
young campaigners gathered on the beach
to send their message
it's just absolutely crucial that
climate is on the agenda for this g7 not
just because
of the pivotal moment in which when with
the climate crisis and also leading up
to cop 26
but also because the countries that are
here have historic responsibility to act
on the climate
and a lot of countries who won't be at
this g7 are already
experiencing the impacts of that first
hand right now
that's the picture in falmouth here in
st ives extinction rebellion have been
holding
their first major protest it is climate
that is top of the agenda
[Music]
more than 500 protesters marched through
some hives
to be frank i feel we just need to come
to our senses
you know we could there's a lot of
science but actually if we come to our
senses
like there are places i can't breathe
because of exhaustion
i want them to listen to what we're
saying and rather than just talking
about things
making a few policies and creating sound
bites
they need to take
[Music]
well the action will continue right
throughout the weekend they are sending
a clear message to the g7 leaders that
it can't just now be
about talk it's got to be about action
with climate change top of the agenda at
the summit
and amongst these protesters
and that's it for now from cornwall
plenty more throughout the evening as
we cover the comings and goings the
twists and turns of this g7
summit but now back to bell for more of
the days thanks
said jonathan uh yes away from the g7
and cornwall the british
medical association which represents
doctors has called
for a delay to the easing of lockdown
restrictions on june the 21st that's in
the wake of a rising number of coveted
infections there are
over 8 000 new cases today it comes as
new data from public health england
suggests the delta variant now that's
the variant that was first identified in
india
is 64 more transmissible within the
household
than the kent or alpha variant cases
of that delta variant have trebled in a
week well meanwhile england's our number
that's the rate at which covid19 is
estimated to be spreading
has jumped to between 1.2 and 1.4
it's the first time the upper estimate
has been that high
since january and it means that every 10
people with covert 19 will pass it to
between 12
and 14 people sky's health correspondent
ashish joshi reports
a festival of summer sports kicks off
tonight with the euros
and the country is ready to save it
hopes are high every day brings us
closer
to freedom day when all restrictions
will be lifted
but that target date of 21st of june
is at risk the delta variant is driving
a surge in infections the hospitality
industry's bounced back
incredibly well um it's been it's been
hard it's been tough but i think people
want to eat people on a drink and they
definitely want to watch football and we
just want to make sure when we do open
that it will stay that way and not have
to close again because it's the opening
the closing
that is destructive for the industry
the number of delta variant cases has
increased
from 12 431
to 42 323
in just a week that's an increase of 243
percent
the delta variant first identified in
india was found in the uk in march it
now accounts
for 96 percent of cases public health
england
estimates that it's 64 percent more
transmissible within households than
previous variants
and vaccines are on average between 15
to 20 percent
less effective against this strain of
covid
after the first dose compared to the
alpha variant
i think it would be gravely negligent
for the government to move ahead with
removing restrictions on the 21st june
given the data now and what we've known
for several weeks
scientists like deputy gurdasani have
been joined by the bma
and nhs leaders in calling on the
government to delay
lifting restrictions they say
hospitalization
rates in the northwest up by 66
are a stark warning you're not just
talking about
delaying freedom day on the 21st of june
but you're calling for
more urgent interventions now we're
seeing exponential growth of cases very
rapidly the current r
is around 1.3 and in some places it's
1.5
and we're seeing rapid growth in cases
and hospitalizations particularly in the
northwest
so unless we do something to curb spread
now we're still heading towards
a large number of hospitalizations
potentially overwhelming the
nhs and large numbers of cases for long
covered
the government is facing pressure not
just from businesses
but a public keen to see life returned
to normal
a lot of the older people is going into
hospitals is there a main reason why we
went to lockdown in the first place so
if a lot of those people have been like
both vaccinations
and they shouldn't be that bad i think
they should just go along with it